you ever get nervous and almost having
anxiety attacks thinking about going to
your employer to ask for rakes because
you don't know how to do it we're gonna
talk about that today
I'm Patrick made of your host of value
tainment and when I think about life I
think about a lot of awkward moments and
typically awkward moments are times when
we have to ask a question from somebody
and we just really don't know how the
right way is to do it this will be an
example here where do you where do you
see this going oh it's a really nice day
out today I mean look at those trees
over there look up green there just
don't see trees like that these days you
don't I mean are you serious Paul we
look up green beds Wow where do you see
this going do we have a future or not or
even listening to what I'm saying you
right now what do we have a future
together or not
I'm not sure I'm following what's so
hard about answering the question hold
on I gotta take this it's Debt
Collection hello yes oh yes I could come
right now not much scheme pumped out
absolutely I got it right now I'll head
right there I got it I got it
so as funny as that may be we do have a
hard time asking two awkward questions
and in business it's how do you go about
asking your employer your boss your CEO
for raise try run my own business and we
have a lot of team members we have a lot
of staff employees and a lot of agents
and one of the things well my w2
employees is a few years ago I set them
and we had a meeting and I said I want
to talk to you about how to ask me and
the company for race it was a very
awkward moment because it's not every
day your employer comes to you and says
here's that I asked for rates and I will
tell you is probably been one of the
best things we ever did as a company
because it taught people how to come to
me for raise and there are a lot of
right ways to ask for raise that we're
gonna talk about today but there are
many wrong ways to not ask for raise
this would be one of the examples of a
wrong way of asking for raise I mean I
don't even know where to begin
I mean looking at these numbers can't
believe we're still in business quarter
one we took a big hit we got to take off
we're gonna take off some of these guys
off the payroll we got to start laying
off a few people this is we can't have
it so what's thinking it's time I get a
raise what do you mean it's time for you
you don't decide that I decide that it's
time to pay me show me the money
sure so if you've ever tried to ask for
a raise that way there's a reason maybe
why you didn't get the raise there's a
right way of doing and we're gonna talk
about that here today okay so first of
all what should the mindset be of
someone who's going to ask for a raise
one I will tell you look at it as you as
the employee you're a brand okay and you
are making the case
this brand you is your client you're the
attorney you're making a case to the
judge the jury your employer your CEO
your boss why this person these are a
two three four or five percent rates
whatever the number is you gotta go out
and look at it that way when you're
speaking to your boss about asking for
rates and your number one best friend
when asking for rates your number one
best friend when asking for race is
mathematics let me explain why your
number one best friend asking when
asking for raises math if you can come
to me and you can make a case why you
deserve a raise based on certain numbers
that you did for instance hey last year
you know you asked the company or goal
was to increase by 25 percent increase
by 39 percent and I made the company
additional six hundred ninety six
thousand dollars out of my department
and I minimize expenses by three hundred
twenty eight thousand dollars I think I
deserve this and great math boom boom
boom makes sense yes you get a raise and
your boss may come back and say I won't
give you five but I'll give you three
and a half great you got your raise
right you know hey I think I did this
number and you asked me to do that and I
increase retention from 17% to 29% which
made the money save a million three last
year and I think based on that I deserve
a four point six percent raise no
problem here's what I think you'll get a
four percent raise great math is your
best friend the more you can make your
argument based on math less about
emotion the better you'll be don't
compare yourself based on you know I've
been here for such a long time I'm such
a nice person I do this that doesn't
matter in business you got to understand
that a business doesn't make it unless
there is performance if businesspeople
got paid and made money and they grew
based on being good people but bad
performers a lot of people would be out
of business today so you got also look
at yourself as well you are yourself in
business you gotta perform to keep your
job and keep growing and increasing your
salary so number one is math number two
efficiency and value so maybe in your
department there is not a way to have
math in your favor although there is in
almost every possible way there is math
but if there isn't because you develop
software and the software does certain
things the software still goes to
retention it goes to efficiency you can
still show speed of getting business to
or getting a loan funded or getting a
product to clients you used to take a 6
days now it's taking us three days to
create the product and get it out but
you've got to also make a case for
efficiency and the value you're bringing
efficiency and value and it's gotta be a
measureable efficiency and value this is
what I designed this is what it did get
us a second one third one when asking
for rates it's very important for you to
be considered of the timing of the
business and the company if it's a
start-up don't ask for a raise when
there's a start-up because even the CEO
is barely making any money the CFO none
of the c-type employs these they're not
making any money for the first few years
when the company's being built because
every money that comes in it's going
back into the business so remember the
timing part of it as well when a
business's being is going through if
it's 2008 and the mortgage industry
going through tough times and you work
for banking you wanna go ask for a raise
bad timing so be considerate of the
timing as well of where the companies
that the company just went in you know
got a loan or bonds or did certain stuff
and you know they have to pay this back
within the next couple years you got to
understand the positioning of where the
company is that when those things are
taking place always be respectful as
you're asking for a raise from whoever
that you're dealing with and last
viñales if this.method I just shared
with you you approached your boss and
they blow you off even though you made
the company millions of dollars and you
can prove it based on numbers and you
still don't give a raise don't get upset
go become an entrepreneur because when
you become an entrepreneur that is the
only way where you really can control
the amount of raise you're going to get
and if your employer doesn't follow a
format like this where you can purely go
make a perfect case for raise and you
still don't get it maybe it's time for
you to start a business or go out there
and become an entrepreneur
and you'll need to work a little harder
for the first few years but you can wake
up on a January first 2020 and say this
year I want to increase my income by 50%
and you can do that because you're
owning a business so you need to
understand the positioning on how to ask
for raise and if you understand how to
ask for raise properly and you go to
them that way generally your boss your
employee or seer is gonna want to work
with
and if not go be an entrepreneur but by
the way if you run a business and you
have staff and you want to teach them
how to ask for raise maybe this is a
good video for them to watch and if you
got a friend who is nervous about how to
ask for raise be sure to share this
video with your friend as well and
subscribe to the channel if you got any
questions comment on the bottom thanks
for watching everybody so number one is
math number two value did you hear what
I just said no is this going anywhere
are we or should we just cut it off now
I don't speak Spanish
alright poem 3 wait act like a child I
this is ridiculous
you should get a cat don't go to zoo are
you done talking
I keep zoning out I'm sorry I've got so
much on my mind right now my dog just
died oh my goodness my dad just had a
heart attack
oh my my house just got foreclosed where
are we taking this can you please grow
up and have a civil conversation for
once in your life well it's just we've
been going through so much the past two
years and you keep avoiding me you don't
you're not taking anything I say
seriously it's like we're just running
in circles all we're doing is running in
circles and we're not moving forward we
it's this is ridiculous you're playing
with my emotions right now
and I don't need my emotions to be
played with I need something serious and
solid Paul